moskau die hauptstadt russlands eine
millionen metropole mit zwei gesichtern
weltoffen und modern aber zugleich
streng und traditionell
wir begleiten sechs schweizer und
schweizerinnen die den mut hatten sich
im wilden osten niederzulassen
in dieser fremden geheimnisvollen welt
die unter präsident putin wieder an die
goldenen zeiten anknüpfen möchte
weshalb haben sich unsere schweizer
diesen ort ausgesucht wie heimisch
fühlen sie sich hier und mit welchen
schwierigkeiten sind sie täglich
konfrontiert
traum oder albtraum abenteuer moskau
[Musik]
kosaken tanz vor dem hotel metropol das
mögen die touristen drinnen versucht
direktor dominique oder noch schnell
alle tendenzen zu erledigen
heute kommen seine liebsten aus der
schweiz er sieht seine frau barbara und
tochter caroline selten genug und nach
moskau kommen sie eigentlich nur drei
bis vier mal im jahr
sie werden in seiner hotel-suite wohnen
platz hat es zwar genug
aber vielleicht wäre ein anderer ort in
moskau entspannender für die gemeinsame
zeit mit dem hotel und ideal
es ist die zeit wo eigentlich hier der
druck zu hoch ist und sagte vier tage
vom 1
und das ist in europa können
etwas außerhalb des zentrums ist
svetlana gucken bühne auf dem weg zum
lager ihres café unternehmens die 26
jährige hat sich auf den import von
hochwertigen kaffeebohnen spezialisiert
sie wird bereits erwartet mitarbeiters
das muss die ladung die heute raus geht
noch verpacken langsam dass es natürlich
wie viel kraft und ich bin froh dass ich
das nicht machen wo es will
die planung ist natürlich auch sehr
heikel mit öffnet viel höher
der pending und sie sind mehrfach
aufwendigen verkauft und natürlich mit
viel geld gekostet den container schnell
mal 60 ein kolumbianischer 80 dollar und
ein äthiopischer über 130 dollar und das
lied alles der lager und mussten so
schwach auftreten
zudem ist die bürokratie in diesem
geschäft nicht zu unterschätzen
kolumbianische büro da ist zwei monate
verspätet also sicherlich papierkrieg
und zudem herrscht zwar nur mit
infrastruktur deine landes tue das heißt
man wirklich das mit café glocke hand
zurück in der stadt ein gemütlicher
familientag bei dorothea kolde am abend
soll es eine überraschung für sie geben
organisiert von tochter sophie aber auch
dorothea hat ein präsent sie hat ein
album ihrer gemeinsamen china reise
gemacht
kaum ein werk das foto passt perfekt zum
hintergrund da war ich sehr stolz
in china waren sie mehrere wochen
gemeinsam unterwegs erstmals mit
umgekehrter rollenverteilung was bei
dieser reise neu war so fico hat alles
organisiert hervorragend zum ersten mal
im leben war ich nicht verantwortlich
das war großartig
[Musik]
das kann man mit dabei war damit kann
droht wir gut leben
zumindest für den moment ich bin nicht
auf der suche nach jemandem ich muss
mich zuerst selber finden
ich muss verstehen was passiert ist aber
wenn ich jemandem begegnet er mir
gefällt dann ja wieso nicht
sophie hat vor später in china oder
europa zu studieren
aber sie möchte ihre mutter auch nicht
alleine lassen das treibt sie um
vielleicht sagt sie es nicht aber ich
weiß dass sie trauriger ist wenn ich
nicht da bin
wir verbringen viel zeit zusammen reden
und lachen viel
für mich ist es auch traurig sie fehlt
mir sehr wenn sie nicht da ist aber
früher oder später müssen die kinder
selbst etwas aus unserem leben machen
studieren und anderswo neues entdecken
moskau die zwölf-millionen-metropole ist
im wandel
die russische hauptstadt putzt sich für
die fußball-wm 2018 heraus und die
schweiz mischt kräftig mit
[Musik]
bauunternehmer roland lay baut mitten im
zentrum ein neues botschaftsgebäude für
die schweiz
modern und repräsentativ mit
wohnresidenz für den botschafter schweiz
als auftraggeber ist natürlich für mich
rein emotional sehr wichtig und diese
forderung als wir haben nicht sehr viele
monteure aus der schweiz - bauer vor
allem china habe der idee profitieren
retro glaswände schaltanlage vom möbel
wäre die ganze holz glas das alter von
thales verzichts auf das eine mini
duelle nico das mit experiment machen
darum hier generell zeit alles was
komplizierte sache sind alles ist der
schweiz und ich denke bis jetzt immer
burg fahren und qualität passt aber
natürlich handeln des herz sich aber
herausstellt heute steht eine kontroll
begeben mit der bauüberwachung firma aus
deutschland an
für roland ein heikler termin weil er
als generalunternehmer für etwaige
mängel haftet auch auf dem bau gilt die
regel zeit ist geld
geraten die arbeiten in verzug kann es
für roland teuer werden
da sehen wir jetzt gerade das problem
mit dem anschluss von putz was wir an
der baukommission sitzung gesprochen
haben wir sind unter termindruck mein
vertrag wird als sympathische der
schweiz mit vertrags finale also mit
vertragsstrafen bauverzug und so weiter
und das alles braucht einfach mehr zeit
also wenn das ganze schweiz stattfinden
würde
russland versucht sich wirtschaftlich
wieder als großer player zu etablieren
im kongresszentrum findet die wichtigste
industrie messe des jahres statt
[Musik]
mittendrin
juli dachte sie muss heute eine
schweizer delegation betreuen
da darf nichts schiefgehen die
delegation ist äußerst hochrangig
schweizer parlamentarier die ihren
besuch in russland nutzen um zu schauen
wie es der schweizer industrie hier geht
begleitet von keinem geringeren als dem
schweizer botschafter iv hier leider
wird chilis zeitplan gleich zu beginn
über den haufen geworfen denn die
schweizer delegation hat überraschend
ein geschenk für ihren russischen
gastgeber im gepäck gut für die stimmung
schlecht für die planung
das mit den christen die belastung aus
dem ausland ich zum schluss im supercup
vor dem rennen gemacht
die reisegruppe ist ungewöhnlich groß
juli ist heute in mehreren funktionen im
einsatz
auch als pressesprecherin für den
botschafter
die 41 jährige hat sich als frau in
russland durchgesetzt
nicht ganz einfach in einer
patriarchalischen geschäftswelt in der
frauen häufig nur als hilfskräfte oder
hübsche dekoration eingesetzt werden hat
sie einen tipp für ihre
geschlechtsgenossinnen
svitlana schafft das problemlos aber
heute geht es ausnahmsweise um etwas
anderes es ums geschäft
die café helferin hat besuch von ihrem
alten tanzpartner med nun wollen sie
schauen ob es noch geht
sie kennen sich aus der zeit in london
die beiden haben neben dem studium
professionell turniere getanzt mit
turniertanz svitlana aufgehört fehlt
hier der leistungssport schon nach den
ersten takten zeigt sich die beiden
tanzen auf höchstem niveau auch wenn die
perfektionistin selbst das etwas anders
sieht dann für macht immer selbst viel
spaß eines lang nimmer gemacht und vor
allem möglichen
natürlich trifft wenn also wenn man
immer bei mir sogar schon woche der
nation aber das gefühl vom tanzfieber
steinschüttung kann man relativ schnell
wieder in stiege
tanzen ist sport und leidenschaft muss
ich es mit landes freund ihren sorgen
machen den reiz für mich ist immer
wieder das wort krieg und mit dem match
hat eine neue tanzpartnerin in london
das wird leider sich einen neuen partner
in moskau sucht ist unwahrscheinlich
musiklehrer priorität im moment ist
schon so dass mir der kaffee tatsächlich
aufgelöst so wo der liter schafft hat
dann zwar nicht viel dank dort am
meisten energie kraft investieren und
das ist eine ideale maria zieht nach
[Musik]
fleiß disziplin und ehrgeiz das sind
eigenschaften die svitlana das tanzen
gelernt hat und sicher helfen sie ihr in
ihrem neuen leben als unternehmerin
lawrence witmer und seine familie sind
auf dem weg zur neuen wohnung
der 40 jährige ökonom ist gerade erst
angekommen und tritt schon bald die
leitung des swiss business hub sun
bis dahin wird sich das neue leben
allerdings noch etwas provisorisch
gestalten wochen gesperrt die sind
irgendwo im lager war sheen nach wie vor
zwischen zwischen pole pole und visums
landwirte schätzen irgendwo die wohnung
hat lorenz online von der schweiz aus
gesucht allerdings erst nachdem klar war
auf welche privatschule sohn juri gehen
würde dass sie hier eine große moderne
wohnung gefunden haben war auch ein
bisschen glück
der mietpreis ist vergleichbar mit
zürich allerdings ging es in moskau noch
viel teurer
alles was im selben quartier das
entwickelt die die quartier wo man sehr
günstigen wohnraum finde aber dass
bedingten hat man muss handeln und so
wiederum dass ich eigentlich privileg
sich nicht eben der schickimicki das ist
es überhaupt nicht aber das ist einfach
als privileg könne relativ zentral
wohnen bevor ich muss er noch mit fünf
metern macht das jetzt muss oder sind
sie bereits mit tempo 20 zone gemacht
aber das kind wird wohl vielmehr das
wird wohl fühlen und das ist gemacht
lorenz beginnt schon nächste woche zu
arbeiten dass die der vermieter ihn
fragt ob sie das kristalline tue damit
ich werde mich als familie vereint in
moskau das gilt heute endlich auch
wieder für dominique potteau
denn seine frau barbara und tochter
caroline wohnen eigentlich in einsiedeln
das hatten sie 2014 wegen der ukraine
krise so entschieden
damals musste caroline eingeschult
werden die zeit die sie zusammen haben
wollen sie aber genießen
[Musik]
so ganz loslassen kann dominique noch
nicht ziel des familienausflugs ist das
berühmte dreifaltigkeitskloster von
sergejew possad außerhalb moskaus
genießt die zeit mit seiner familie sehe
in die erziehung seiner tochter mischte
sich nicht gross ein
[Musik]
klar dass ich mich natürlich an den
orten in flussnähe auch wenn ich den
hype in den original toyodas nicht
sicher zu machen und glauben sondern
dass sie auch probiert die gleiche linie
wie textil sowie muss ehrlich sagen paul
bereich viel strikter als ich aber
genialen also mission group nur an allen
die mutter das ist ganz frau kümmert
umso mehr schmerzt vorzeitige wo das
mitmachen und ich weiß dass man sich
jetzt mache ich ein kind familie zählt
und das ist ja die entschädigung regen
macht hofer hat die russland führen sind
immer etwas besonderes wie ist es denn
wenn papa dominik mal zu hause ist
[Musik]
zwei bis drei mal im monat fliegt
dominik oder in die schweiz und
verbringt dort ein paar tage mit seiner
familie auch während der schulferien
sind sie fast immer zusammen
an diesen rhythmus haben sich
offensichtlich alle gewöhnt und doch
tochter caroline wächst mehrheitlich
ohne ihren vater auf gut dass auftrag in
moskau wird noch mehrere jahre dauern
und dafür braucht man eine vertiefte
bisher und das ist eigentlich nur nach
oben
nachdem die titel der heimischen
intensiv nach einer entsprechend
zusammen verbringen
zurück in zentrum der therapie sind auf
dem weg zu einem töpferkurs den hat
sophie ihrer mutter geschenkt im taxi
diskutieren sie über alles mögliche auf
einmal auch über den präsidenten
wladimir putin
ich mag ihn sehr ich weiß nicht warum
als ich klein war und ihn im fernsehen
sah schrie ich mein bruder mein kleiner
bruder das hat sie aber nicht von dem
ich das hatte ich auch nicht dorothea
hat putin schon mehrmals direkt erlebt
das erste mal habe ich in einer stadt
unvergessen er saß gerade hinter mir
habe ich war wirklich schockiert von
seinem weg der war kalt er hatte
dermaßen durchdringende augen ich hatte
noch nie einen solchen harten und kalten
blick gesehen ein freundlicheres treffen
hatte sie 2014 im schweizer haus
anlässlich der olympischen winterspiele
in sotschi
dort war auch dorothea mit mütze vom
morgen an sagte man uns putin kommt wir
mussten uns ja richtig aufstellen um ihn
zu empfangen
dann kam ihr er hatte sehr gute laune
dorothea wollte unbedingt ein gutes foto
von ihm machen und wartete auf den
richtigen moment plötzlich sahen wir uns
an
er lächelte ich machte das foto genial
dem präsidenten steht sie nach wie vor
ambivalent gegenüber
er ist mir nicht besonders sympathisch
aber ich würde ihnen gerne mal treffen
er macht seinen job für russland ich
verstehe dass man ihn im westen nicht
sonderlich liegt aber in russland macht
er für die meisten wohl gute arbeit
auch der neue chef des swiss business
hub lawrence witmer ist im auto
unterwegs obwohl sein büro nur gerade
zwei kilometer von zuhause entfernt
liegt
[Musik]
im prinzip laufen
das erscheint möglichkeiten es kurz
frisch war das kalorien in wahrheit für
mich zum 200
das weiß ich noch nicht so recht habe
das auf das wir pflügen die de facto
ausgesetzt
es ist sein erster arbeitstag lorenz
soll neue strategien entwickeln damit
sich schweizer firmen stärker auf dem
russischen markt engagieren
sein neuer arbeitsplatz ein
hochsicherheitstrakt denn der business
hub ist der botschaft angegliedert
lorenz hat schon einen eigenen schlüssel
heute wird lorenz seinem team
vorgestellt tief morath lorenz vorgänger
ist anwesend und natürlich schwach gold
vorgänger yves wechsel nach china
lorenz job bleibt ihr womöglich
schwierigere aufgabe er muss trotz krise
frischen wind in die russisch
schweizerischen geschäftsbeziehungen
bringen
die do's and don'ts ohne und eben ganz
besonders diese tipps gibt es allerdings
hinter verschlossenen türen café
händlerin svitlana hat heute frei
genommen
nach dem anstrengenden training mit matt
haben sie eine stärkung verdient
es gibt georgische leckereien vom
lieferdienst mit lynas freund tieren
kommt vom training nach hause
svitlana spielt die hausfrau
[Musik]
märz ist charmant und gut aussehend ist
das für kevin ein problem
[Gelächter]
dorothee und sophies in dem töpfer
atelier angekommen seit sie auf einer
reise nach armenien schöne alte vasen
gesehen hat möchte dorothea unbedingt
selber versuchen etwas zu töpfern
sophie hat es möglich gemacht hier
gibt's ablenkung vom alltag und
entspannung
dann geht es zur sache
meister roman empfiehlt eine ruhige hand
behalten und keine angst haben etwas
kaputt zu machen gleich gesagt
[Musik]
so fällt es leichter die 20 jährige hat
auf anhieb das richtige
fingerspitzengefühl bei mutter dorothea
klappt es nicht ganz so gut
[Musik]
was für ein bild mit dem noch fürs leben
ich brauche man müsste sich einfach
gehen lassen aber ich habe mich gehen zu
lassen er sagt ich sei angespannt aber
ich bin halt immer angespannt auch im
leben das ist einfach so ich müsste mich
besser entspannen
es wird abend in der 12 millionen
metropole blieb acht und ihre familie
sind auf shoppingtour beim schwedischen
möbelgiganten ikea in sachen konsum wird
der wilde osten eben immer westlicher
juli hat sich extra eine liste gemacht
und wie sind die preise verglichen mit
der schweiz
drei filialen betreibt ikea allein in
moskau
weitere läden sind geplant die schweden
treffen auch in russland den richtigen
nerv
also wohin du hast du irgendwelche
vorstellungen davon wie man lebt wie man
ihn fest ich weiß es viele leute hierher
kommen damit sie den pflege etwas
frisches durch jeder weiß das möbelhaus
inspiriert nicht nur sondern kann bei
geschmacksfragen zur echten beziehungs
probe für paare werden
alles andere ist relativ problemlos lief
ende
heute gibt es leider kein groß schreibt
kurz vor der kasse ab juni dann doch
noch in eine der berühmten ikea konsum
fallen
[Musik]
mittlerweile steht russland hinter west
europa amerika und asien weltweit an
vierter stelle der wichtigsten
absatzregionen für den möbelhersteller
globalisierung sei dank
inzwischen gibt es auch in der
russischen hauptstadt viele
möglichkeiten sich am abend zu vergnügen
jedenfalls für die die es sich leisten
können
svitlana kirn und tanzpartner matt haben
beschlossen noch auszugehen
ihr ziel eine coole musik kneipe um die
ecke
während im nebenzimmer eine geschlossene
gesellschaft einen geburtstag feiert
erwartet mit lana vorne im saal ihre
cousine olga eine wichtige bezugsperson
in ihrem leben
das wissen all diese versammlungen
die show
auch beruflich arbeitet schon seit
jahren in familienunternehmen der
gruppen - wie sieht's svetlana er als
schweizerin oder doch als wohin das ist
eine schwierige frage für mich ich kenne
sie seit ihrer kindheit wahrscheinlich
seit sie 34 jahre alt ist also seitdem
ich 19 jahre
sie ist für mich in erster linie eine
schwester ich kann nicht sagen ob sie
mehr russen oder mehr schweizerin ist
sie ist ein interkultureller menschlich
weiß nicht für mich ist sie
wahrscheinlich eher ein russe fragt man
jedoch ihre geschwister in der schweiz
dann ist sie für sie wahrscheinlich eher
eine schweizerin
[Musik]
nur etwa 800 schweizer und
schweizerinnen leben in moskau 2500
kilometer von der heimat entfernt
eine handvoll ist vor kurzem dazu
gekommen
familie widmen die neue wohnung ist
bezogen nur die verschärften möbel
lassen auf sich warten aber zumindest
tun papa lorenz und sohn juri schon also
als würden sie einrichten dass ein
logistisches problem soll technisches
problem
es wird hart fläche bietet also aber
kennt wichtig
endlich hat das warten ein ende der
umzugswagen ist da
[Musik]
2700 kilometer haben die möbel hinter
sich hoffentlich fällt nichts mehr
jedes einzelne strukturen abkürzen
lorenz hat den kompletten hausrat
verschifft eine ganze vergangenheit in
einem lkw die wichtigste frage für sohn
juri lautet wo sind die spielsachen
doch wohin mit dem ganzen zeug zum
beispiel gibt es einen des bürgerheims
und und der heimat gefunden
der wackere als klein kommt dass man mit
china das kann
bauunternehmer roland lee führt seine
firma schon seit über 20 jahren für
papierkram muss er jeden tag extra etwas
zeit einberechnen ja unterschrieben oder
viel sich halt habe sehr bürokratisches
land und willi direktor der firmung und
jahr die dokumente unterschrieben und
wir sind im tag weiß es nicht
2 300 dokument der vertrag die
mitarbeiter dass das was im erinnerte
ihn zum unterschrieben dass das alles
passt
das könnte ja gerne da alles selber
kontrollieren sich roland ist sein
eigener chef und beschäftigt über 350
leute dass er das risiko alleine
schultert erhöhten druck der auf ihm
lastet gibt es probleme muss er manchmal
dampf ablassen muss ich mich um das
kümmern also ich verstehe das nicht
roland wird streng aber herzlich sein
ziel die mitarbeiter zu selbstständigem
arbeiten und mehr eigenverantwortung zu
erziehen sind mitarbeiter natürlich sehr
wichtig da ist kapital für die firma
darüber lacht frage kann ich auf wenn es
geld dazu aber eine gute mitarbeiter
wobei mentalität unserer firma mitmacht
und mitdenkt
die themen mehr pflegen und die tonica
pflege denken
hollands größte sorge ist dass er
vielleicht leute entlassen muss jetzt
die krise sieht zwei york new york
die spürarbeit so extrem wie life risi
investoren auftraggeber den wichtigen
momenten in russland es mit der harmonie
luft weg
[Musik]
besser läuft sie im hotel metropol ein
roter teppich und feine sachen bereits
am morgen
[Musik]
dominique fouda hat diesen tag zur
chefsache erklärt heute kommt kein
geringerer als der japanische
premierminister
da muss alles stimmen solche besuche
sind fürs prestige sehr wertvoll da ist
mit der die relegation und entsprechend
haben wir jetzt die früchte und wie und
champagner für die wichtige 10 wieder
vorbereitet und die demnächst system
rufe und entsprechend sind wir nicht
fertig kontrollieren und würde das alles
gerichtet ist alle details werden
durchgecheckt die neuen luxussuiten im
hotel metropol sind noch nicht ganz
fertig auch die präsidentensuite nicht
darum muss man aus der bestehenden das
beste herausholen nicht funktioniert
nicht fehlen darf ein persönlicher
begrüßungs brief und entsprechende
wünsche ihren erfolgreichen und
angenehmen aufenthalt
die spannung steigt geheimdienst und
sicherheitsleute haben unten das zepter
übernommen
der empfang für premierminister schien
so abe angereist mit seiner gattin aktie
geht einwandfrei über die bühne
würde dominik oder alle
staatsoberhäupter so begrüßen zb auch
den syrischen präsidenten baschar
al-assad hatte sie sich auf jede gültige
kosten durch die russische hauptstadt
fließt die moskwa hier am ufer des
imposanten flusses trifft sich roland
lay auf einem exklusiven der
restaurantchef regelmäßig mit ein paar
engen schweizer freunden zum lassen
[Musik]
alle drei sind erfolgreich im
finanzwesen tätig und unterhalten gute
geschäftsbeziehungen zu russland die
westliche kritik an präsident putin
sehen sie typisch schweizerisch neutral
eben gedanken ich sehe europa zu erhöhen
berlin berlin sprach verbuchten auf
deutsch und euro prämien sind halt auch
nach oben herab das klinikum behandelt
und wohngebäude zu sagen hinter dem
wirtschaftswoche eine stelle wo vom
material bis hin nach wladiwostok die
grenze ziehen wo geschützt werden dass
europa wirtschaftlich brutal stark
gemacht
riesig war für amerika wesen und die
chance haben einfach verdammt und das
ausland gemacht hat sie sind sie werden
geopolitisch wird aber genau und ich
glaube dass wichtig bislang sie die
schweiz fährt einen anderen kurs als die
eu und zieht daraus einen klaren vorteil
das gute image der schweiz als ich mit
den meisten überzeugte im usc bereich
angriffe der hand im konflikt mit
georgien wir haben die verschiedenen
also eigentlich wollte die promi status
cool
das tor stand für roland gibt es ein
weiteres indiz dafür dass die schweiz in
russland langfristig mitspielen will
die baustellen von der botschafter für
die größte investition aber schweiz
macht im bereich botschaften im ausland
und das bedeutet für mich frau das tolle
von der schweiz suchen diplomatisch
sektor sicher bieten die ich in russland
und auch in zukunft werden sie die
kleine eigensinniger schweiz unterwegs
als global player in russland im moment
weiß allerdings niemand so genau wie
sich diese fernbeziehung entwickeln wird
in der nächsten folge geht es ins grüne
lorenz und seine familie besuchen
schweizer freunde auf deren dacia und
müssen gleich mit anpacken
außer dem hotelier dominique fouda und
sein spitzenkoch andré suchen regionale
delikatessen auf dem markt nur das beste
gut genug und dorothea unterwegs in den
ural
die expertin für menschenrechte
überprüft die arbeitsbedingungen auf
russischen baustellen vor der fußball wm
ein großes thema